in 2015 billionaire elon musk announced
starlink a satellite-based internet
provider that would put so many
satellites into space that it caused
alarm
amongst astronomers in 2018 tesla one of
his companies announced the ability to
add air-powered rocket thrusters to
their vehicles and he's been very public
about his desire to build a
transformable submarine car
all i'm saying is that elon isn't even
trying to pretend that he doesn't want
to be batman and so let me just put it
out there elon i volunteer to be your
robin here's my resume
hello internet welcome to film theory
where
one last note about elon musk he might
be trying to be batman in real life but
did you know that he's actually the
inspiration for robert downey jr's iron
man in the marvel verse quote from an
interview with jon favreau the film's
director when i was trying to bring the
character of genius billionaire tony
stark to the big screen in iron man i
had no idea how to make him seem real
robert downey jr said we need to sit
down with elon musk and
the rest is history friends anyway today
we're talking about everyone's other
favorite eccentric billionaire bruce
wayne aka
the batman who recently got himself a
bunch of new announcements
in case you missed him since 2020
continues to suck and that suckitude
includes things like comic-con being
cancelled dc took it upon themselves to
host an entirely separate online event
called
fandom where they could update all of us
about their new projects we saw the
snyder cut of justice league which you
know
looks like justice league we saw info
about james gunn suicide squad 2
called the suicide squad which you know
has got to be the dumbest naming
convention since the release of the wii
u
but really does look like a cool project
there are some new video games coming
out that look like a lot of fun wonder
woman's new movie still looks promising
but of course the biggest news was the
drop of a new teaser for the batman
with its grounded world realistic
looking costumes and dark atmosphere the
batman is shaping up to be more of a
detective noir film than any of the
bat's previous movies which is pretty
exciting since you know batman is
supposed to be the world's greatest
detective but we rarely see that put to
full use in the movies like how cool is
it that batman can just casually stroll
into a crime scene midday to work
alongside the gotham police department
and it
seems like the movie has the perfect
villain to match wits against him
the riddler making his long overdue
cinematic appearance since um
who's afraid of the big black pack
was that over the top i can never tell
let's
just say that this new batman probably
won't be featuring quite as many
bedazzled
question mark leotards now loyal
theorists subscribe to the channel will
remember that last year we were able to
predict
many of the big twists of joker a month
before it was released into theaters
this time i think we can do one better i
think that we can call many of the big
plot points and reveals of the batman
a full year early using information from
the trailer
what we know about the production crew
interviews and just a little bit of
general movie knowledge i think we can
pull a batman for ourselves and solve
the riddler's game before the movie
is even done with production it'd be a
new all-time record for us i gotta say
so what do you think
wanna play so last year when we did this
dance for joker a lot of our conclusions
were based on movies that the director
listed as his stylistic inspirations
and by inspirations he really just meant
ripping off entire plot points
in that case it was the martin scorsese
classic king of comedy which hinted at
the fact that not everything in the
movie was gonna be real
and that there was going to be a strong
usage of hallucinations and dream
sequences
joker used a lot of the same mechanics
but hey audiences didn't seem to mind
that it was just king of comedy with a
comic book skin over top of it to the
tune of earning
1 billion dollars worldwide and so i
don't think it's too much of a stretch
to assume that dc saw that success and
said hey
let's do that again shall we this time
matt reeves the director of the batman
has already gone to list the movie
chinatown
a dark 1970s detective movie as one of
his
primary inspirations for his film and
while chinatown is a classic
and yes i think that that movie's story
of citywide corruption is probably a big
inspiration for the batman's plot
i mean it is gotham after all corruption
just kind of comes with the territory
i'm not gonna focus on that film today
because i think dc learned something
from the last time that we did this
dance
because we were able to put so much
together so early last time i think dc
might have told matt reeves to stay
quiet about some of his more
direct influences nice try guys but i
see you i've got it all figured out
based on the scenes that we've been
shown in the trailer i believe that the
batman
will follow the work of david fincher
award-winning director behind
psychological thriller movies like 7 and
zodiac because the stories behind both
of these movies are so important to
today's theory i'm gonna briefly go over
both so here's a spoiler warning for
both of these movies
7 and zodiac one of which contains the
most frequently spoiled movie moment in
history what's in the box
what's in the box and let me just say if
you've never seen these films especially
seven
watch them they're great they're super
influential in the genre of crime
thrillers like i'm just a big fan even
if seven does do that stupid thing where
a number is supposed to be the letter
like seriously doesn't even look like a
v anyway
so seven in tells the story of two
detectives morgan freeman and brad pitt
uh
sorry summerset in mills it's just
sometimes hard to separate these guys as
anything but themselves anyway somerset
is one week from retirement when the
movie starts and mills is the relatively
new guy who's supposed to take his place
their first and only case together is to
try and solve a string of serial
killings based around the seven deadly
sins where the culprit
john doe leaves clues and riddles for
the detectives to solve or
fail to solve quite honestly because by
the end of the movie they totally fail
to stop the killer seriously he has to
turn himself in
realize detective the only reason that
i'm here right now
is that i wanted to be no no we would
have got you eventually
allowing five innocent people to die
and at the end of the movie his plan is
complete there are seven victims and
he's played the detectives right into
his own hands we'll get into more
specifics about the crimes in a minute
the other david fincher movie i want to
call out is zodiac based on the real
story of the zodiac killer a serial
killer in california who sent a series
of letters
and riddled ciphers to california
newspapers announcing his killings to
the world hmm
more riddles go figure the movie comes
down pretty hard on one suspect in
particular but much like the real life
case the guy is never
caught or convicted he goes free he wins
rather than focusing on the guy who did
it the movie actually focuses on the
people
investigating the case and the massive
toll that it took on their lives now
i'm not just calling out these movies
because they're both gritty
psychological thrillers that
stylistically look very similar to the
batman trailer and feature
detective characters trying to solve
riddles sent by a deranged killer
though let's be honest that's already a
lot of similarities no what made me
convinced enough to do a theory about
this is the fact that industry insiders
have alluded to the fact that the batman
movie wouldn't just feature one villain
or two
or three it might have six here's the
quote from hollywood reporters heap
vision newsletter matt reeves is still
tweaking a script which is rumored to
have at least
two villains the penguin being one of
them according to sources one person is
telling us
there will be around half a dozen
villains we're hearing of another
perfect character making an appearance
in the script as well
jeez half a dozen i mean it seems like
too many to believe
has no one no one learned anything from
spider-man 3
or amazing spider-man 2 or well really
just a lot of spider-man movies with too
many villains crammed in
it seems like this absolutely insane
number of villains but
matt reeves himself has gone on record
to say that the movie will
feature a rogues gallery of villains
again
implying a lot of characters here and
this seems to hold up when you look at
what information we've gotten so far
from the production
riddler penguin and catwoman all feature
in the trailer so we know that those
three are definitely in there
we also know that john tutero is cast as
carmine falcone who well not a super
villain per se is often one of batman's
biggest villains
rumors about two-face have also been
swirling since the movie first started
filming and while no actor is definitely
playing the character
charlie and max carver are identical
twins who are both cast in the movie in
as of yet
unnamed roles given two faces common use
of twins as henchmen this casting
doesn't seem like that much of a
coincidence and makes it likely that
two-face will probably show his face
somewhere
so already it seems like you're dealing
with five known villains
meaning that a sixth wouldn't be that
far of a stretch now i go over
all of that because including batman it
would make seven key characters it's an
interesting number considering that
seven function the same way six victims
and the seventh
being the young detective mills the one
investigating the serial killings
and unlike all the other victims mills
isn't killed
instead it's his idealism his moral code
that
shattered at the end of the movie again
spoilers for the movie but the killer
john doe pushes detective mills to the
brink by offing his wife and chipping
her head in a box to the middle of the
desert mills
fires on the shackled and helpless john
doe and in the process creates the final
two victims in john doe's masterwork
jon and himself representing envy and
wrath it's a story that slots perfectly
in with a younger batman
one who based on interviews about the
movie is only in his second
year of being a rodent-themed sleuth
quote from matt reeves about the movie
the idea
is that we're in year two it's the
gotham experiment it's a criminological
experiment he's trying to figure out
sort of what he can do to finally change
the place and in our story
as he's in that mode that's where you
meet him and he's seeing that he's not
having any of the effect that he wants
to have yet and that is when the murders
start to happen so a young
more innocent and idealistic batman is
presented with a series of murders
committed by the riddler and eventually
the last victim
will be batman himself where his
commitment or moral code is broken
somehow don't believe me
in the trailer riddler directly calls
out
how am batman part of this
you'll see it's eerily similar to an
exchange that we get in seven so when
this big thing happens
you'll be sure and let me know because i
wouldn't want to miss it oh
don't worry you won't
you won't miss a thing no don't get me
wrong i don't think that we'll be
following the seven deadly sins or
anything literal like that but i do
think that the riddler's goal in the
batman will be very similar
to what we see of john doe in 7. the
trailer shows us that the riddler likes
literally leaving
writing on walls seven's killer also
like literally writing on the walls
clearly wanting to send a message with
his murders we see a deadly sin
on every street corner we tolerate it
because it's common well not anymore
and what i've done is gonna be puzzled
over and studied
forever sounds like a message that could
also apply to gotham a city full of
corruption
and greed as matt reeves says himself
the murders begin to describe
sort of the history of gotham it opens
up a whole new world of corruption that
went much farther oh yeah and then
there's the music for the batman trailer
something in the way not only is this a
really great song but it's also
supporting this theory since it's a song
by nirvana the iconic grunge band that
exploded onto the scene and helped shape
the course of music all through the 90s
it's a sound very much of that decade
and when was seven released
1995 smack dab in the middle of the
decade where nirvana was at its height
just call out what i see as an
interesting coincidence when asked about
the comic book influences matt reeve
mentions
batman ego which was a dark story about
the mental toll being a superhero takes
on a human
it poses that classic batman question
can bruce wayne and batman
ever truly coexist we'll find out today
dang it joel schumacher i thought i told
you to stay out of this anyway ego
touches on bruce's obsession with
vengeance and justice
and how the costs can be immense
likewise both seven and zodiac deal with
the passion and ultimate disillusionment
of crime fighters
in seven detective somerset starts a
week away from his retirement because he
can't see the point in going on with
what he's doing by the end of the movie
he's
kind of changed his mind ernest
hemingway once wrote the world is a fine
place
and worth fighting for i agree with the
second part meanwhile detective mills
lets his passion take control
ultimately leading to his own ruin when
he murders an unarmed prisoner
it feels like the dynamic between jim
gordon the hardened police officer
versus batman's wild passion for justice
okay okay or vengeance by the way i
wouldn't be surprised if this was the
final scene in the movie where
very clearly he just beat that guy to
death right we can all agree that that
guy is probably dead and if batman's
moral code is hey i'm working with the
detectives i don't kill people
maybe this is batman after his moral
code's been broken and he's like you
know what i'm gonna have to kill people
just putting it out there is a
hypothesis anyway in zodiac it's the
same thing
the main character robert greysmith
starts as an innocent cartoonist but
over the course of the movie devolves as
he obsesses over the case trying to
solve the riddles
ignoring his wife forcing his kids to
work on solving the case with him and
ultimately putting his own life on the
line to solve the crime but what you may
have noticed through all of this is that
neither zodiac
nor seven have particularly happy
endings in zodiac the killer gets away
with it and in seven
the killer gets exactly what he wanted
given that batman is going up against
one of his most brilliant villains there
is more than a good chance that the
riddler
is gonna wind up with what he wants to
and so that begs the question
what does he want well outside of
breaking the bat in a way that doesn't
involve his back i believe that he wants
to dismember what's known as the court
of owls
remember how i said that there was one
last slot open for another supervillain
well i think it might all be tied to a
group of villains known as the court of
owls the court of owls is the shady
cabal of gotham's wealthiest citizens
who actively influence crime in the city
for their own benefit in the comics the
waynes were always fighting against the
court of owls and it wouldn't be much of
a super stretch to guess that maybe the
court of owls was tied to the death of
batman's parents you know i always make
fun of movies for showing the batman
origin story for like the thousandth
time but it is
really hard to talk about batman and not
talk about his parents murder
or as matt reeves put it when talking
about his movie without being an origin
tale for him
it ends up being something that touches
on his origins in fact the court of owls
is actually hinted at by the card
that the riddler leaves for batman which
features an owl
backed by a skeleton we see batman
actually beating that skeleton later in
the teaser so that card might be more
literal than it first appears
it's also worth calling out that the
court of owls has a peculiar penchant
for kidnapping young boys and
transforming them into murder ninjas
called
talons young boys who grew up to become
murder ninjas where have i heard that
one before
talons get themselves a cool uniform
that has a hood and goggles that
looks awfully similar to riddler's
goggled face mask from the trailer
but i think riddler wasn't a successful
talon i think he escaped and he wants
vengeance the card riddler left for
batman is from your secret friend which
indicates that at least
riddler sees himself as an ally for
batman's cause so we have ourselves one
person who's trying to solve gotham's
crime problem
violently in the riddler and another
person who's probably trying to solve it
in a less violent way in batman and by
the end of the movie batman has to
change his moral code
since the court of owls is actively
making crime worse in the city taking
them out even if
violently may actually help solve
gotham's crime problem which is exactly
what matt reeves claims batman is trying
to do
he's trying to figure out what he can do
that can finally change this place
so in the end here is how i see the
movie the batman playing out
six crimes with the seventh victim being
batman himself the riddler's goal
through his murders is to bring light to
the corruption of gotham corruption
led by the court of owls and in the
process get batman to question his own
moral code by exposing the wayne
family's role in all of it
or potentially exposing that batman
himself was the product of the court of
owls
that revelation shatters batman which
leads him to breaking his own code in
the end
ultimately killing someone perhaps even
the riddler himself thereby making
batman a vigilante rather than a trusted
member of the detective squad oh and uh
i also predict there will be zero
appearances of bejeweled riddler suits
so am i right am i wrong looks like
we're gonna have to find out in um
30 71 10 91 2061 based on how 2020 has
been going
that last riddle might be the most
unsolvable of them all
but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and
cuts riddle me this how can you help
film theory cross
10 million subscribers stat the answer
to that one is actually shockingly easy
you just click the red subscribe button
down below ring the bell if you want to
get notified but no skin off my nose if
you don't i just really want to cross 10
million subscribers on this channel one
day soon i think it deserves it this
channel works really hard we work really
hard on this and hey if nothing else if
this theory ends up not being true just
consider this your own personal head
canon an alternate equally viable
route for how this movie could go will
it be better will it be worse i don't
know but it's worth subscribing to find
out